Payan Sharifi lives in an elegant
Imperial era apartment in the heart of
Berlin hello welcome to our home please
come in higham is an iranian-american
artist and writer his home is a
reflection of his extensive travels
around the world from which he's brought
back a treasure trove of furniture and
art every item has a story to tell this
piece in the in the center of the room
is a sculpture by a polish artist and
the who's name is Bhaskar novitskiy and
the sculpture is called speeches silver
and it's a mold of a throat referencing
the punishment during medieval times for
blasphemy or heresy was to pour molten
silver down the throat accents of color
provide a striking contrast to the white
walls the stuccoed ceilings were freed
of decades of paint with painstaking
care at the center a Czech cubist
chandelier
[Music]
we've been wanting to have this piece in
our home for about 15 years and when we
first saw it in Prague in early 2000s we
couldn't afford it so we had our parents
buy for themselves and and about 13 14
years later we managed to afford one for
our own home hyeyeon shares the 100
square metre apartment with his wife he
admits he's happy to let her make
decisions when it comes to the decor
please meet kasia my partner she's
designed the whole apartment and she
began with this moroccan door this door
was made in Morocco and a friend of
Cash's had actually an extra one here in
Berlin that we were lucky enough to have
and and this was a kind of first stone
that was set in this apartment and
what's special about the doors it really
gives you a different impression of
being transported to a different realm
or to a different space when you walk
through it come with me
[Music]
breathable tiles lend the bedroom a
Mediterranean feel what happens is it
creates a microclimate everybody knows
that it's healthier to sleep in colder
climate room temperatures and instead of
having to open the windows or you have a
draught for example here the cold sort
of envelops you or surrounds you an
array of decorative objects from Asia
and Africa give a sense of ethnic
identity and soul to this home in the
middle of Berlin wooden chairs animal
pelts and hand-woven carpets create a
rustic feel and infuse the airy space
with boho chic touches the artists
collective Slavs and Tatars feel at home
in this cozy space the living room is
dominated by a large daybed this is
called a Toth or we call it a river bed
it's a kind of vernacular piece of
furniture that you find often outside
near a river in cafes in parks and in
places like Iran where unmarried men and
women can't socialize together the river
bed becomes one of the unique spots
where women and men can mingle
traditional handiwork combined with
contemporary art this apartments
eclectic mix of styles is as much an
invitation to settle as it is to travel
the world
you